[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau 2 face aux territoires sur tv5
monde avec nos partenaires vous le savez
ouest france vous pouvez nous regarder
sur ouest france.fr nice-matin
nicematin.com
franceantilles.fr aussi avec un léger
décalage dû aux fuseaux horaires aux
antilles est aujourd'hui à partir
d'aujourd'hui notre nouveau partenaire
du groupe la montagne centre france
c'est la république allait parlons
l'arep point fr qui nous diffusera ce
matin la république du centre voilà mon
invité ce matin c'est elisabeth bornes
bonjour elisabeth board merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes ministre du travail
de l'emploi et de l'insertion pas
d'autres de non ça m'occupe bien déjà
vous docu bien déjà bon bien vous
démarrez ce matin membres du
gouvernement sur un plateau de matinale
on ne peut que vous vous posez des
questions sur ce convoi de la liberté
donc qui arrive à paris est le préfet de
police d'ailleurs a interdit les
manifestations à paris ce vendredi de ce
convoi de la liberté ce qui a pas une
forme eu d'inquiétude ou c'est un
gouvernement de voir monter
ce convoi de la liberté au moment où la
campagne présidentielle va démarrer
écoutez je pense que c'est traduit le
fait qu'il ya certainement beaucoup de
fatigue après des longs mois de crise et
puis aussi le fait que certains
mouvements radicaux qui depuis là aussi
le début de la crise veulent capitaliser
sur cette fatigue des français moi ce
que je note c'est que la situation
sanitaire est en train de s'améliorer
savait qu'on a déjà levé beaucoup de
contraintes sanitaires le cas à celle
qui existait depuis le 2 février par
exemple où le td travail obligatoire on
a ri ce qu'ils entendent ça ceux qui
sont dans les convois qui monte à paris
qui veulent manifester et exprimer leur
colère est ce que c'est à un disco qui
peuvent en attendant je pense que ça
reprend des mouvements qui existe dans
d'autres pays c'est peut-être important
de souligner que contrairement à nos
voisins on n'a pas du tout des
restrictions sanitaires aussi forte vous
savez si on prend les pays bas à la
veille de noël il ya eu un confinement
qui a été décidée il ya eu beaucoup
fermetures de commerces chez nous
voisins en france on n'a pas eu ces
restrictions on est évidemment attachés
à trouver le bon équilibre entre la
protection de la santé le fait de ne pas
avoir une pression trop forte sur nos
hôpitaux et en même temps de pouvoir
vivre le plus normalement possible et ça
on a pu le faire parce que les français
ont massivement répondu sur le vaccin
parce qu'on a aussi un pass vaccinale
qui nous permet de maintenir l'activité
malgré une situation sanitaire qui était
quand même tendues ces dernières
semaines on va parler de travail bien
sûr on parlait emploi on va parler
insertion c'est elisabeth bord de la
ministre du travail qui est notre invité
ce matin en face aux territoires les
chiffres de la productivité en france ne
sont pas mauvais et ils sont même mon
néanmoins le rapport des français au
travail
est-ce que c'est pas quelque chose qui
vous préoccupe est-ce que c'est pas un
défi pour le gouvernement il ya eu dans
les 35 heures il ya le télétravail le
journal 20 minutes me disaient qu'ils
avaient dans leur courrier des lecteurs
des témoignages de jeunes qui refusent
des jobs parce que ces jobs ne sont pas
en télétravail est ce que le rapport des
français au travail le retour dans
l'entreprise ne vous pose pas problème
il forcément eu beaucoup de
bouleversements avec par exemple comme
vous l'avez dit recours au télétravail
comme on n'avait jamais eu jusqu'à
présent et ça va se changer tout au fond
y compris les mentalités est ce que ce
que vous avez anticipé ça commence le
jeu note changé c'est que des gens qui
ont pu prendre du recul on va dire du
fait de la crise attendez c'est le cas
notamment des jeunes mais c'était aussi
déjà un peu le cas avant la crise
veulent du sens dans leur travail ils
choisissent leur entreprise aussi en
fonction de son engagement sociétal donc
je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'important qu'il faut que les chefs
d'entreprise entendent que les jeunes
veulent un métier qui a du sens et il y
en a évidemment en termes de
productivité ça changera rien alors sur
la productivité vous savez qu'avec le
traité d travail il ya un certain nombre
de métiers pour lequel ça augmente la
productivité je pense qu'il faut aussi
être attentif à l'importance du
collectif de travail et je pense qu'avec
ce télétravail les français ont aussi vu
à quel point le travail c'est un endroit
où on croise des collègues on échange
c'est un lieu de sociabilisation tout ça
ça a été exacerbée par ces mois de
télétravail et ses crises sanitaires
françois-xavier l'offrande de ouest
france nous rejoint sur ce plateau dans
un instant
bonjour françois xavier le franc vous
êtes rédacteur en chef de ouest france à
d'abord mis et higuain francophone du
monde l'apprentissage nous concerne
beaucoup oui alors il ya des choses qui
vont bien en france l'apprentissage va
bien en france avec une progression
spectaculaire du nombre des contrats je
crois qu entre 2021 2020 c'est 37 % de
plus alors évidemment tout ça coûte de
l'argent et france compétence qui est
l'organisme qui gère les fonds de la
formation professionnelle et de la
france et de l'apprentissage accuse je
crois un déficit de 3 milliards 7 alors
est ce que cette belle dynamique parce
que son étude ne va pas être freiné pour
des raisons budgétaires alors d'abord je
crois que c'est effectivement important
de dire qu'on a battu tous les records
sur l'apprentissage on est à près de 720
mille jeunes qui ont signé un contrat en
2021 ces chiffres il était inimaginable
je pense avant la crise il ya beaucoup
22 promettez de gauche comme de droite
de développer l'apprentissage non nous
l'avons fait c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour les jeunes parce qu'on a
un taux d'insertion dans l'emploi qui
est très très important on a six jeunes
sur 10 malgré la crise sanitaire qui
avaient un emploi six mois après la fin
de leur apprentissage pascal 2011 1 donc
c'est vraiment la voie d'excellence pour
se former en découvrant le monde
professionnel et avec très souvent à la
clé un job évidemment ça engendre des
dépenses mais je peux vous assurer que
on est vraiment convaincu qu'il ne faut
pas casser cette dynamique
donc c'est jusqu'à 20 juin voire jusqu'à
fin juin on y compris des aides pour les
entreprises qui embauchent un apprenti
et après vraiment c'est l'intérêt de
notre pays des jeunes des entreprises de
notre économie de continuer à soutenir
l'apprentissage elisabeth board ministre
du travail est notre invité ce matin
d'en face aux territoires le président
de la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
des îles qui s'appelle guillaume cairou
à une question à vous poser madame la
ministre télé 78 la rencontre et de
l'ecoute
madame la ministre
2021 a été une année exceptionnelle sur
le plan de l'apprentissage avec 718
mille contrats d'apprentissage dans le
même temps il a été créé près d'un
million d'entreprises sur nos
territoires ma question est donc très
simple
quelles actions comptez vous mettre en
oeuvre pour transformer ces apprentis en
futur chef d'entreprise
le président de la république comptent
ils faire de la france une véritable
terre d'entrepreneurs
alors évidemment c'est très important de
créer son entreprise et on soutient
notamment dans le cadre du plan un jeune
une solution la création d'entreprise
mais moi ce que je note c'est que
l'apprentissage mène aussi très souvent
à créer ou à reprendre une entreprise un
on sait que par exemple dans le domaine
de l'artisanat moi j'étais en début de
semaine à la remise des premiers
trophées de la chambre des métiers et
d'artisanat
il y avait beaucoup des dirigeants des
responsables départementaux des chambres
des métiers et d'artisanat qui étaient
d'anciens apprentis qui avait pu
justement soient créés soit reprendre
l'entreprise de leur patron à son départ
en retraite donc c'est aussi une très
bonne voie l'apprentissage pour devenir
chef d'entreprise cette émission elle
est dédiée aux territoires label
diversité des territoires français et
quand on est sur les territoires on voit
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprises d'élus
d'élus régionaux d'élus départementaux
qui parle des métiers en tension il ya
énormément de métiers en tension
aujourd'hui c ur de métier qui ne
trouvent pas de salarié alors
l'apprentissage ça peut aider à ça mais
comment aider ce tissu
industrielle le tissu des entreprises
les élus à régler cette question là qui
est pas qui ne se réglera pas d'un
claquement de doigts comment faire en
sorte que les formations correspondent
aux besoins et comment faire en sorte
que qu'on règle cette question des
métiers en tension qui est un vrai sujet
comme vous le dites l'apprentissage
c'est une très bonne voie et quand on
est une entreprise qui a des difficultés
de recrutement
s'engager dans l'apprentissage c'est une
bonne idée puisque ça permet de préparer
les compétences dont on a besoin demain
mais on a aussi depuis le début du
quinquennat investi massivement dans la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi ces 15
milliards d'euros sur le quinquennat
comptes consacre à la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi on vient quasiment
doubler l'effort des régions je rappelle
que c'est des régions qui sont
compétentes sur la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi en septembre dernier
avec le premier ministre on a voulu
aller encore plus loin d'annoncer un
plan de réduction des tensions de
recrutement 1,4 milliard d'euros de plus
pour précisément bien former les
demandeurs d'emploi pour qu'ils aient
les compétences dont les entreprises ont
besoin et on veut vraiment être très
concret c'est-à-dire favoriser
l'immersion en entreprises des
demandeurs d'emploi pour que lente le
chef d'entreprise l'employeur puisse
vérifier que le demandeur d'emploi
correspond bien à ses attentes et
ensuite on finance des formations
vraiment sur mesure pour répondre aux
besoins des entreprises alors ouest
france qui est coproducteur de cette
émission françois-xavier l'offrande et
le rédacteur en chef et rencontré
fabienne car 0 qui est une chef
d'entreprise elle y voit elle pose la
question comment le jeune entrepreneur
peuvent-ils obtenir des nouveaux droits
en écoute
bonjour de la ministre leur vie
d'entrepreneur n'a jamais été aussi
forte dans le pays allah dit nous
finançons des entrepreneurs qui n'ont
pas accès aux prêts bancaires ces
entrepreneurs ont des droits sociaux
plus limités que ceux des salariés
puisque notre système a été basée avant
tout sur le droit des salariés
aujourd'hui ils ont besoin comme les
salariés d'avoir des droits pour se
loger des droits pour leur santé des
droits à la formation c'est pour ça
qu'elle a dit milito pour la convergence
des droits entre salariés et
indépendants sur ce sujet mme dana
ministre de quelle manière situerait
encore la bandera genou droit des
indépendants pour donner à l'accès le
plus grand nombre à la création de leur
propre emploi la pâte fabienne 15 02
puis rennes alors d'abord je voudrais
dire qu'on soutient la 10 ans
précisément parce que c'est d'un des
réseaux qui accompagne la création
d'entreprise et vous savez qu'on le
parlement vient de voter une loi sur les
indépendants pour sécuriser leur statut
pour qu'ils soient pas mis en cause sur
leurs biens personnels s'il peut y avoir
une défaillance d'entreprise je pense
que c'est important qu'on encourage la
prise de risque la création vas-y
reprise absolument et c'est bien voilà
on veut vraiment soutenir tous les
créateurs d'entreprises et les chiffres
de l'an dernier montrent aussi que cette
politique elle marche alors que la
question concernant les jeunes qui
démarrent dans le monde du travail et
les entreprises qui utilisent encore
beaucoup les contrats à durée déterminée
on voit bien la souplesse que ça leur
apporte mais comment est ce qu'on fait
quand on est jeune qu'on a peu de
revenus qu'on doit trouver un logement
qu'on veut que d'être acheté une voiture
qu'on veut aussi profiter de la vie
c'est à dire qu'on veut démarrer dans la
vie si on n'a pas cette garantie de
l'emploi et bonjour le logement les
propriétaires et ils font pas de cadeaux
volatile aujourd'hui l'emploi va mieux
il ya deux il ya moins de chômage faut
d'ailleurs sont félicités est-ce que
c'est pas le moment de donner un petit
coup de pouce pour que un jeune qui
démarre ne soient pas condamnés à des
cdd à répétition mais vous savez que
c'est l'un des objectifs de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui est à la fois
de favoriser le travail en s'assurant
que c'est toujours plus intéressant de
travailler que d'être au chômage je
pense que ça paraît de bon sens mais ce
n'était pas le cas précédemment
et puis on a aussi mis en place un
système de bonus malus pour encourager
précisément les entreprises à proposer
des contrats de travail plus long je
pense que c'est aussi l'intérêt de tout
le monde ça permet de travailler
davantage et ça évite effectivement la
précarité que vous avez mentionné il
avait dormi str du travail notre invité
ce matin d'en face aux territoires avec
ouest france charlie habib qui a une
question à vous poser sur les
dispositifs de retour à l'emploi
tv5monde la rencontre et on écoute
madame la ministre bonjour certaines
entreprises ont du mal à recruter sur
des métiers en tension alors que
certains demandeurs d'emploi ne trouvent
pas de débouchés dans leur secteur vous
avez mis en place le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
pour favoriser un retour au plein emploi
et pourtant dans les faits des refus de
prise en charge des dossiers de
formation et des cirques une décision
très long pénalise ses recrutements que
proposez-vous pour simplifier l'accès à
l'emploi par la formation pour les
demandeurs d'emploi alors on n'a jamais
formé autant de demandeurs d'emploi vous
savez que c'est 1,5 million de
demandeurs d'emploi qui ont pu être
formées en 2021 un record à 600 milles
au début du quinquennat donc on n'avait
si je le disais massivement dans la
formation et puis on veut des formations
très concrète ce qu'on appelle les
préparation opérationnelle à l'emploi
c'est à dire celles qui permettent à
l'entreprise de former le salarié en
situation de travail à ses besoins
précisément mois si le monsieur qui
vient de nous parler à des suggestions à
faire pour être encore plus efficaces
moi je suis à son écoute je pense que
quand on a cinq cent vingt mille
demandeurs d'emploi sans aucune activité
la catégorie ya de moins donc en 2021 ça
montre que cette politique elle porte
ses fruits on se régale et est-ce qu'on
n'est pas là devant pour vous les
politiques un vrai défi on est en pleine
campagne électorale pour la
présidentielle on se plaint que les
jeunes ne votent pas c'est vrai que
votre très peu les jolies se passionne
pour la politique les questions de
formation et l'emploi salle et ça les
préoccupent ça les préoccupent beaucoup
ou est-ce qu'il ya pas là un vrai défi
pour arriver enfin parler aux jeunes en
cette période sans les culpabiliser en
essayant de leur donner un peu envie
d'aller de l'avant parce que il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de messages qui
leur sont adressées qui sont qu'ils sont
noirs or là il ya des choses qui vont
bien alors comment comment faire vous
savez la jeunesse ça a été notre
priorité puis début du quinquennat et a
fortiori dans la crise on a voulu éviter
à tout prix ce qui s'était passé après
la crise de 2008 2009 on avait eu une
explosion du chômage des jeunes aux plus
de 30 % de jeunes demandeurs d'emploi de
plus après la crise de 2008 2009 c'est
pour ça qu'on a lancé le plan un jeune
une solution en juillet 2020 pour
permettre à chacun de trouver son chemin
vers l'emploi ça a très bien marché on a
4 millions de jeunes qui ont pu
bénéficier d'une des solutions du plan
un jeune une solution on n'a jamais eu
un taux d'emploi aussi élevé depuis 30
ans les ja de l'après du taux de chômage
qui a baissé et on continue bien
évidemment à accompagner des jeunes vous
savez que à partir du 1er mars on en
sera le contrat d'engagement jeunes
pour les jeunes encore trop nombreux
dans notre pays qui malgré la bonne
situation économique n'arrive pas à
accéder à l'amp qui sont en situation de
précarité et bien donc c'est vrai pour
les étudiants c'est vrai pour des jeunes
qui commencent d'ampleur pour ces jeunes
qui ne retrouvent pas tout seul un
emploi on veut proposer vraiment un
accompagnement personnalisé
intensif 15 à 20 heures par semaine
d'accompagnement avec justement d
immersion en entreprise pour découvrir
des métiers de la formation et donc on
lança à partir du 1er mars et pôle
emploi les missions locales qui pourront
accompagner tous ces jeunes pour qu'ils
puissent trouver au plus vite un emploi
les nouvelles bornes show nuque et le
dessinateur et collaborateurs de ouest
france à une question à vous poser sous
forme de dessin c'est une tradition de
cette émission en garde saunier
le week-end dernier les britanniques ont
fêté les 70 ans de règne de leur
souveraine qui n'est pas prête de
prendre sa retraite donc la question que
je vous pose madame la ministre si
emmanuel macron grill
accepteriez vous de revenir deuxième
fois au ministère du travail bien pour
vous attaquer à cette sacrée réforme des
retraites abandonné en cours de chemin
vous entrerez ainsi dans l'histoire sous
le nom
et isabelle 2
[Rires]
alors s'il allait mal et le maquereau
aurait eu pour rempiler au travail
écoutez c'est pas moi qui en décide ce
qui est clair c'est que la réforme des
retraites ça sera une priorité du
prochain quinquennat avec la crise
évidemment il n'a pas été possible de
mener cette réforme c'est un sujet très
important à la fois pour équilibrer
notre pays nous financement le
financement de nos retraites et plus
généralement de notre protection sociale
aussi parce que dont on est un pays dans
lequel on travaille plus longtemps moins
que d'autres voilà donc il faudra
travailler plus longtemps il faut aussi
un système plus juste et plus lisible
donc c'est une priorité du prochain
quinquennat avec la une de ouest france
françois xavier lorre et bien là une de
ouest france air nationale un dossier
complet pour que chacune et chacun
puisse comprendre cette grave crise
internationale frontières de l'ukraine
et de la russie
évidemment le sommet des océans à brest
parce que la question des océans une
question majeure au supplément capital
merci françois xavier le front ouest
france dans un instant armelle le goff
de 20 minutes sur ce plateau
bons joueurs mais de le goff vous êtes
la directrice de la rédaction de 20
minutes partenaires de cette émission
dans un instant on en vient à vous mais
tout de suite cyril bouttier depuis les
antilles depuis fort de france il est
directeur éditorial de france-antilles
donc un journal partenaires de cette
émission à une question à vous poser on
les écoute depuis fort-de-france bonjour
madame la ministre vous avez évoqué la
baisse des chiffres du chômage en 2021
une baisse qui est constatée également
dans les territoires d'outre-mer aux
antilles et en guyane même si elle est
moindre qu'en france métropolitaine
on pense notamment aux tranches d'âge
jeune dans lesquels le taux de chômage
est encore important
quels sont donc les leviers que le
gouvernement pourrait activer pour
continuer cette baisse des chiffres du
chômage dans nos territoires
alors effectivement là si tu vas le
chômage a baissé dans les départements
d'outre-mer comme sur tout le territoire
mais les chiffres restent élevés plus
élevé 1 qu'en métropole c'est pour ça
qu'on a mobilisé 1 5 milliard d'euros
dans le cadre du plan de relance pour
soutenir les entreprises accompagner les
jeunes les demandeurs d'emploi pour
qu'ils retrouvent un emploi on a aussi
des dispositifs particuliers pour les
jeunes par exemple avec la mission
locale de guadeloupe notamment pour
aider sur la garde d'enfants sur la
mobilité on a ra on augmente les
contrats aidés aussi pour permettre à un
maximum de jeunes d outre-mer de pouvoir
retrouver un emploi voilà salaires et
pouvoir d'achat maintenant avec vous et
arben leboeuf oui tout à fait vous avez
parlé d'emplois des jeunes avec
françois-xavier lefranc un sujet
intéressant concernant l'emploi des
jeunes et qui fait le lien avec le sujet
des salaires que je voulais aborder avec
vous ce sont les salaires des jeunes
cadres dont la moyenne a diminué en 2020
par rapport à 2019 ce sont les chiffres
de l'apec contrairement aux cadres en
général alors on sait qu'il ya une
tension sur les salaires aujourd'hui
comment est-ce que cela se fait que les
salaires des jeunes cadres aient diminué
alors là vous citer des chiffres de 2020
était quand même une assez particulière
avec la crise sanitaire 2021 on a une
reprise très forte de notre économie et
on voit que l'emploi des cadres aussi
s'est redressée il ya beaucoup d'
embauches et j'ai pas de doute qu
effectivement cette bonne dynamique du
marché de l'emploi va aussi permettre
d'avoir des meilleures saveurs intimiste
à moi je suis très optimiste sur les
possibilités pour les jeunes en général
pour les jeunes cadres en particulier de
trouver un emploi et donc qu'ils sont
aussi dans une bonne situation pour
négocier leurs salaires elisabeth borde
la ministre du travail est notre invité
ce matin denis carot les acteurs la
rédactions du groupe nice matin question
à vous poser on écoute
bonjour et isabelle borne avec le retour
de l'inflation les français en plus en
plus de mal à boucler leurs fins de mois
or si aussi nickel a été réévalué de 3%
en donnant ce n'est pas le cas forcément
des bas salaires est ce qu'il existe des
pistes pour inciter les entreprises ou
les branches professionnelles à
réévaluer les petites rémunération vous
savez qu effectivement on a un certain
nombre de branches qui ont des plusieurs
niveaux dans leur grille salariale les
premiers niveaux qui sont en dessous du
smic évidemment les gens sont payés au
smic c'est la règle dans notre pays mais
ça veut dire que pendant plusieurs
années ils ont pas de perspectives de
progression salariale moi j'ai demandé
aux branches professionnelles y en a une
quarantaine qui avant l'augmentation du
smic au 1er octobre avait déjà des
niveaux inférieurs au smic d'engager
sans délai des négociations il ya
beaucoup de branches 1 qui ont entendu
ce message par exemple la branche des
hôtels cafés restaurants qui représente
beaucoup de salariés qui a revalorisé
ses grilles en moyenne de 16% et ben moi
j'invite toutes les branches qui n'ont
pas encore fait à salir valoriser aussi
leur grille salariale pourquoi par
exemple ne pas revaloriser le smic comme
l'a fait l'allemagne ou comme l'ont fait
les pays bas et s'est récemment alors le
smic en france on a un des systèmes les
plus protecteurs homme au monde puisque
il est revalorisé
normalement tous les 1er janvier pour
tenir compte de l'inflation et de
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat cette
année avec effectivement une
accélération de l'inflation il a même
été augmenté au 1er octobre donc ce smic
il est revalorisé on a aussi été très
attentif au pouvoir d'achat des salariés
et qui sont au smic avec à la fois la
suppression de certaines cotisations
sociales les cotisations chômage et
maladie avec le l'extension et
l'augmentation de la prime d'activité
pour un salarié qui est au smic dans le
quinquennat ils touchent un 13e
l'équivalent d'un 13e ou d'un
quatorzième mois selon sa situation
familiale donc on est vraiment très
attentifs en même temps là on a un sujet
particulier avec la flambée des prix de
l'énergie il ya eu beaucoup de mesures
qui ont été prises à la fois une aide
exceptionnelle pour les six millions de
bénéficiaires du chaque énergie
l'indemnité inflation le blocage des
prix du gaz et de l'électricité en tout
cas la limitation pour l'électricité sur
le gaz c'est d'équivalent de 900 euros
de pouvoir d'achat
économiser pour les français 300 euros
sur l'électricité puis plus récemment on
a aussi revaloriser les indemnités
kilométriques donc on est vraiment très
attentif à ces sujets de pouvoir d'achat
et les branches ou évidemment aussi leur
rôle à jouer comme je le disais
elizabeth dans un instant va parler des
seniors avec armelle le goff mais tout
de suite notre nouveau partenaire du
groupe centre france la montagne qui
intègre cette émission va maintenant
intervenir depuis orléans c'est florent
buisson de la rédaction de la république
du centre une question à vous poser en
écoute madame la ministre gouvernements
et entreprises se renvoient la balle sur
la question des salaires que ce soit en
région centre val de loire où je me
trouve comme partout en france
concrètement aujourd'hui jeudi 10
février 2022 que peut faire l'état pour
augmenter les salaires en france foot et
je tiens à dire cité des mesures
importantes à grossir votre exemple et
la wii mais qui rend la question plus
générale les mesures qui ont été prises
face à la flambée des prix de l'énergie
qui concerne tous les pays dans le monde
ça représente 15 milliards d'euros donc
je pense que l'état a vraiment mis le
paquet pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat
des français il ya aussi la
revalorisation du smic les discussions
sur lequel on pousse les branches à
avancer et je pense qu'effectivement il
faut que ces négociations elles se
tiennent dans les branches et dans les
antilles mais il ya une vraie tension
quand même on voit que les par exemple
les salariés de lustucru en région rhône
alpes sont en grève actuellement ils
réclament 150 euros sur des moyennes de
salaires qui sont à mille quatre cents
par mois il ya un vrai sujet quand même
enfin j'ai pas de doute qu'il ya
beaucoup d'attentes sur ces sujets de
pouvoir d'achat y compris au sujet de la
campagne électorale compris parce qu'il
ya eu aussi des bons résultats dans
beaucoup d'entreprises au cours de
l'année 2000 21 savait qu'on a aussi
proposé avant la reconduit la prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat la
prime battrons comme on dit qui a déjà
bénéficié à près de 4 millions de
français c'est une prime sans charges
sociales sans impôts les entreprises qui
n'ont pas encore utilisé je les invite
aussi à le faire si elles ont eu des
bons résultats au cours de l'année 2021
les seniors les seniors si jamais il
devait y avoir un 2e mandat d' emmanuel
macron et une réforme des retraites il
ya quand même un sujet c'est
l'allongement de la durée de travail
alors que les seniors on le voit ne sont
pas forcément souhaité dans les
entreprises qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
là dessus alors vous avez raison si on a
effectivement et je suis convaincu qu'il
faut le faire une réforme des retraites
il faut s'occuper du maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors on l'a vu un même
pendant la crise un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui ont eu tendance à
proposer des préretraites à faire partir
les seniors je pense qu'on se prive
quand on fait ça de l'expérience de
salariés qui est quelque chose
d'extrêmement précieux pour les
entreprises donc c'est un jeu un dossier
à un sujet qu'il faut aborder en même
temps que la réforme des retraites ça
pose des questions de formation tout au
long de la vie on a de nombreux outils
pour se former tout au long de la vie
par exemple avec le cpf le compte
personnel de formation et puis il ya
aussi des enjeux des métiers dans
lesquels il ya une usure professionnelle
donc à la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle auquel il faut être
attentif donc c'est un volet qui est
tout à fait complémentaire d'une réforme
des retraites alors justement par
exemple la modulation du temps de
travail certains économistes aujourd'hui
considèrent que le taux de chômage est
en bas l'insertion à la fois des jeunes
et des seniors dans la durée serait
serait facilitée par une modulation du
temps de travail à la baisse pourquoi ce
n'est pas un sujet qu'on puisse qu'on
peut et que voulait dire de baisser le
temps de travail je prends exemple est
en france un des pays dans lequel on
travaille le moins sur l'année tout au
long de sa vie c'est aussi un enjeu de
compétitivité de notre économie je pense
que ce qui est important c'est qu'on ait
une économie compétitive et concret un
maximum d'emplois c'est d'abord ça qui
est important pour les français mais des
entreprises comme total pense par
exemple alors je crains qu'il puisse y
avoir des entreprises qui proposent
quatre jours de travail par semaine
comme levée totale c'est leur choix mais
voyez je pense pas du tout que ce soit
une solution pour l'ensemble des
entreprises on est des expériences qui
avait pu se passer au moment des 35
heures soit vous proposer de faire le
même travail en quatre jours ce que vous
faisiez en cinq jours et c'est aussi
beaucoup de stress pour les salariés
beaucoup de pression sur les salariés
soit il s'agit de travailler moins et
alors on parle du pouvoir d'achat c'est
clair que ça a un impact sur le pouvoir
d'achat sera pas un des enjeux de la
campagne électorale justement ça cette
différence que les français perçoivent
dans leur travail en fonction des
entreprises dans lequel il travaille le
public ou le privé ce que vous pensez
pas que ça peut être un sujet de
fractions ça je pense que des
entreprises qui sont dans des situations
différentes dans des métiers différents
donc c'est normal qu'on ait des
différences qu'il faille aller vers plus
de justice plus d'équité c'est ce qu'on
poursuit notamment au travers de la
réforme des retraites par exemple avec
la fin des régimes spéciaux mais ensuite
des situations d'entreprises qui sont
différentes et on va pas avoir une règle
unique pour toutes les entreprises il ya
aussi des discussions qui doivent se
tenir du dialogue social au sein des
entreprises est ce qu'il ya un problème
à avoir dit pendant des années qui
avaient une complication augmenter les
salaires à cause des charges des chefs
d'entreprise et puis tout d'un coup
cette crise sanitaire a vu mise
l'économie emmanuel macron au fond doter
la france de 2 milliards pour affronter
cette crise est ce que est ce que les
gens peuvent comprendre ça pendant des
années on leur a dit c'est pas possible
et tout d'un coup les milliards étaient
là ils avaient deux bornes mais vous
savez dans le quinquennat on a aussi
beaucoup agi je le disais pour le
pouvoir d'achat mais la perception
qu'ont les gens de ça il n'y avait pas
d'argent mais tout d'un coup il y en a
eu cet argent il a été mobilisé pour
protéger les entreprises b12 n'avait-on
pas avant 1 on a mis ce que les gens se
posent à mobiliser des financements
exceptionnels pour protéger les français
ça a été le cas sur l'hôpital pour
protéger nos entreprises ne pas détruire
d'emplois ça permet à notre pays de
repartir de façon très dynamique ça
permet à beaucoup de français de trouver
un emploi un je redis 520 mille
demandeurs d'emploi aucune activité de
moins je pense que c'est des gens qui
voient bien un impact sur leur pouvoir
d'achat quand on retrouve un emploi la
première réponse c'est aussi celle de
permettre à chacun d'avoir un emploi sa
une de 20minutes d'hier puisque
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de 20 minutes
oui 20 minutes paraît trois fois par
semaine et il a une c'est sûr concernant
les jeunes qui sont âgés de 18 à 30 ans
et qui considère que même si leur
candidat est élu pour plus de 50%
d'entre eux ça ne changera pas leur
situation oui enfin je pense que c'est
très important de montrer que
effectivement la politique on agit sur
des choses très concrètes je vous citais
leblanc un jeune une solution savez 4
millions de jeunes qui ont pu bénéficier
d'une des réponses du plan un jeune une
solution un taux d'emploi donc la part
des jeunes qui a un emploi qui n'a pas
été il n'y a pas été aussi élevé depuis
30 ans je pense que c'est des réponses
très concrètes des jeunes qui signe un
contrat d'apprentissage qui vont pouvoir
apprendre un très beau métier peut-être
reprendre une entreprise demain c'est
des réponses très concrètes merci
armelle le goff directrice de rédaction
de 20 minutes elisabeth borne est notre
invité ce matin en face aux territoires
dans un instant des maîtres korkmaz de
tv5 monde
[Musique]
bonjour des maîtres merci d'être là d'
déficit commercial entre autres et oui
la balance commerciale atteint un
nouveau record quasi 85 milliards
d'euros en 2021 or on a l'impression
qu'au cours de ces dix dernières années
on a mis en place des mesures et
pourtant on n'arrive pas à remonter nos
exploits de nos exportations à
l'étranger que faut-il faire alors vous
avez raison de dire qu'effectivement le
solde des échanges de biens a été très
négatif cette année mais il faut aussi
regarder globalement et c'est
heureusement positif très positif sur
les services sur les revenus donc on
n'est pas loin de l' équilibre au global
cette balance sur les biens elle s'est
aussi dégradée du fait de l'augmentation
du prix de l'énergie vous savez que
c'est près de 18 milliards d'euros liée
à cette augmentation des prix de
l'énergie
ça montre une chose c'est qu'il faut
évidemment sortir des énergies fossiles
qui non seulement ont un impact négatif
sur la planète sur le hadra d'achat des
français mais aussi sur notre balance
commerciale pour gratuit il faut
poursuivre la
réindustrialisation de notre pays la
politique de compétitivité de
réimplantation d'industrie on l'a vu
aussi à quel point c'était important
dans la crise sanitaire depuis 2019 la
france est le premier pays européen sur
les investissements étrangers et ça a
permis par exemple en 2021 de créer 140
mille emplois industriels alors vous
parlez de cette année exceptionnelle un
la pandémie nous sommes bien d'accord
sauf que le problème est structurel
puisque ça fait 20 ans que nos
exportations sont en recul et en trente
ans la part des produits français vendus
à l'étranger a régressé quasiment de 60%
donc ça n'est pas un problème
conjoncturel lié à la flambée des prix
de l'énergie il y a un vrai souci en
france du positionnement peut-être de
nos entreprises sur
sur ces produits les pme n'arrivent pas
exporter contrairement à nos voisins
européens
les les mesures se sont enchaînées
est-ce que là on n'arrive pas à un
niveau de blocage parce que les les
industries qui sont partis à l'étranger
ne vont pas revenir en france l'objectif
c'est bien on redéveloppe de l'industrie
en france v on est on a détruit avant le
quinquennat pendant dix ans elle a
détruit un million d'emplois industriels
et moi je me souviens d'une époque où
certains plaidé pour un pays sans usines
il faut évidemment sortir de cette
logique recréer de l'industrie dans le
cadre du plan de relance on a eu
beaucoup de soutien à la création de
nouvelles de nouvelles industries en
france et il faut continuer dans cette
voie et certainement accéléré c'est tout
l'objet aussi de france 2000 trempe
savez qui le plan qui a été annoncé par
le président de la république qui vise à
positionner notre pays sur des
technologies d'avenir dans les
transports dans l'énergie dans la santé
il faut recréer de l'emploi industriel
sur notre sol elisabeth board de marcel
radnic et chefs d'entreprise à nice dans
les alpes-maritimes compare les plantes
dette dans le monde il a une question à
vous poser leur écoute à l'heure où joe
biden signe un décret en faveur du made
in america pour leur budget de 600
milliards d'achats publics et où
d'autres pays en font de même fin pour
autant le faire savoir prévoyez-vous
quelque chose de similaire pour le
budget de 200 milliards d'euros pour la
france
je pense que ces importantes que les
achats publics soient bien au service
aussi de notre souveraineté française et
européenne fait qu'on a fait preuve d'un
peu de naïveté dans ce domaine là je
peux vous assurer que c'est quelque
chose que le président de la république
porte par exemple très quand on a
demandé à des entreprises françaises de
fabriquer des masques au plus fort de la
crise va aujourd'hui quand on passe des
marchés publics pour acheter des masques
il faut se souvenir qu'on a souhaité
avoir des entreprises en france qu'il
faut aussi continuer à les soutenir en
sortie de crise lors vous avez parlé
précédemment de l'écologie il y a là
aussi un effort à faire là aussi nous
sommes
la france est en retard par rapport à
ses objectifs
est ce que vous pensez pas que cette
ce secteur pourrait rapporter aussi des
nouveaux métiers pour compenser
justement la fuite alors vous savez on a
enfin je pense que c'est important parce
que surtout j'entends certains candidats
yannick jadot pour ne pas le nommer
qu'il nous explique emmanuel macron
serait le président de l'inaction
climatique
moi j'ai été ministre de l'écologie je
peux vous assurer que ce quinquennat on
a beaucoup avancé sur l'écologie sur des
investissements massifs pour relancer le
train on n'avait jamais autant mis
d'argent pour remettre en état new line
nous petite ligne pour relancer des
trains de nuit on a aussi investi sur
les énergies renouvelables
on crée on a fait une loi anti
gaspillage que peut être un peu passé
inaperçu vous savez qui a été votée en
2020 pour sortir du tout jetable passé
au réemploi à la réparation je suis
convaincu que c'est un gisement énorme
d'emplois comment vous expliquer alors
que ce domaine est complètement fin
passe à la trappe du débat présidentiel
écoutez j'espère bien qu'il va revenir
dans la campagne et je vous dis on a un
bilan à défendre sur ce sujet sortir du
plastique à usage unique par exemple
développer les énergies renouvelables
sept sont des enjeux très importants
aujourd'hui les énergies renouvelables
ne représentent que 166 mille emplois
c'est encore très très faible j'en
profite pour vous poser une autre
question si on ne faisait pas de doute
vous voyez que par exemple sur l'éolien
offshore
c'est des filières sur lequel la france
doit se positionner sur l'hydrogène sur
l'hydrogène vers ce sont aussi des
filières dans lesquelles on doit pouvoir
créer beaucoup d'emplois savait qu'on a
implanté aussi en france on en est à la
troisième
giga factory des très grandes usines
pour fabriquer nos propres batteries
évidemment c'est des sources d'emplois
majeur il ya la question en allemagne le
ministère de l'économie un large
portefeuille qui couvre également
justement le climat les énergies
renouvelables est-ce qu'on ne pourrait
pas un peu feeling au portefeuille en
gros est-ce que ça on pourrait à coller
un ministère du travail avec un
ministère de l'écologie pour justement
prendre promouvoir ses emplois je suis
pas sûr qu'après lui ça vous intéresse
que ce soit un enjeu de découpage
ministériel l'écologie ça doit être ça
doit être pris en compte dans toutes les
politiques
et évidemment moi en tant que ministre
du travail ancien ministre de l'ecologie
suis très attentive au développement des
emplois liés à la transition écologique
je le redis dans la réparation dans le
recyclage on a des gisements d'emplois
très important je croise beaucoup de
jeunes créent aussi des entreprises
précisément sur tout sur tout le
recyclage le réemploi la réparation
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous avez des
nouvelles de ségolène royal dont vous
avez dirigé le cabinet a nommé des
grands pas de nouvelles désolé j'ai pas
pouvoir vous donner vous ne vous n'avez
pas de contact ne réclame pas vraiment
de contacts non je pense qu'on n'est pas
tout à fait d'accord sur beaucoup de
sujets
une question sur l'intelligence
artificielle le numérique tout toutes
ces données qui arrive évidemment et que
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui on veut avoir
appris à prendre en compte dans les
années qui viennent est ce qu'on est
bien préparée en france à ça est ce que
par rapport à des pays anglo saxons mais
pratique ça depuis longtemps pas sur les
états unis extrait ce qu'on dépend ce
qu'on n'est pas en retrait est ce que
vous n'avez pas l'impression que on est
moins bon que que les autres la tiens
vous savez je pense qu'en france on a
des écoles de mathématiques qui sont à
la pointe on a certainement beaucoup
d'atouts pour se positionner sur
l'intelligence artificielle qu'on
n'entend pas se voir là il faut et bad
boy évidemment former des jeunes dans
ces domaines c'était un des secteurs
prioritaires qu'on a mis en avant sur
les formations supplémentaires qu'on
propose aux jeunes tout ce qui est
autour du digital et puis peut-être dire
que ça pose aussi beaucoup de questions
sur le travail demain avec
l'intelligence artificielle moi j'ai
souhaité qu'on puisse avoir un programme
de recherche action hausse avec mon
ministère pour réfléchir aux
conséquences de l'intelligence
artificielle sur le travail demain la
campagne emmanuel macron vous y croyez
votre candidat bientôt vous allez des
confidences
pas énorme non absolument pas c'est lui
qui décidera qui dira le moment venu
comment on fait pour être ministre et
qu'une campagne électorale démarre comme
ça on fait comment on vous continuer une
activité dans les services ne freine pas
savoir comment ça va moi j'ai un
objectif notamment j'en ai dit un mot le
lancement au 1er mars du contrat
d'engagement jeunes pourront continuer à
accompagner tous des jeunes donc on agit
jusqu'au bout ne va pas vous taxé
d'électoralisme
en faisant ça enfin vous souhaitez la
continuité du plan un jeune une solution
on a protégé les jeunes n'y a pas eu
l'augmentation du chômage des jeunes
qu'on nous annonçait mais il faut
s'attaquer effectivement à tous les
jeunes qui malgré la reprise ne
trouveront pas un emploi donc on va agir
jusqu'au bout et en même temps
évidemment on a un bilan à défendre
alors en parlant oui en parlant emploi
on a un gros point noir qui n'est
absolument pas abordée c'est le chômage
des étrangers qui est le double du
chômage des nationaux est ce qu'il n'ya
pas aussi quelque chose à faire pour
avoir une adéquation entre ces étrangers
qui arrivent sur notre sol et alors il
se dit beaucoup de
l'approximation moi j'entendais monsieur
zemmour ou nous dire qu'il y avait 55
ans ans d'inactivité chez les étrangers
hors union européenne ce qui est
évidemment faux il ya un taux d'activité
de 65% mais on a certainement à agir
mieux le taux de chômage représente
quand même 14
certainement à agir à leur fin et ont
notamment sur l'insertion
professionnelle des réfugiés c'est un
sujet sur lequel on travaille avec
gérald darmanin il avait d'abord votre
quotidien tc koala vous continuez donc
dans le ministère tous les jours à faire
des déplacements aller en région vous
faites comme si la campagne électorale
n'existait pas non mais moi je continue
à agir surtout par exemple je vous parle
de ce contrat d'engagement jeunes lundi
j'ai eu un échange avec tous les
conseillers de pôle emploi des missions
locales des associations de lutte contre
la pauvreté qui vont le mettre en oeuvre
et on continue à agir jusqu'au bout dans
l'intérêt je voudrais faire quoi après
je sais pas je pense pas que ce soit un
sujet qui passionne les français bien
sûr mais on dirait vous voulez faire
voyez on est ciel sera au travail après
on est sur des sujets qui sont très
importants quand on s'occupe
effectivement de permettre à des
demandeurs d'emploi de retrouver travail
quand on s'occupe de permettre à des
jeunes d'arriver plus vite sur le marché
du travail je pense que c'est des sujets
qui me tiennent à coeur merci elizabeth
board ministre du travail de l'emploi et
de l'insertion vous étiez invité de face
aux territoires sur tv5monde merci dé m
korkmaz vous pouvez regarder cette
émission en repli bien sûr sur les site
de ouest france.fr notre partenaire co
producteur de nicematin.com co
producteurs hexagonaux franceantilles.fr
avec le léger décalage dû aux antilles
et l'arrêtent point fr notre nouveau
partenaire du groupe la montagne centre
france merci on se retrouve jeudi
prochain et programme continu sur
tv5monde mercialys apaisant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]